Do you remember that
container ship, the Ever Given,
that got stuck in the
Suez Canal back in 2021?
The final report
into what happened
came out a few months ago,
as I record this,
and there were a lot of
things that went wrong.
It was travelling too fast,
there were communications
problems between
the crew and the local pilots,
and there was the
bank effect.
There are two ways
to learn what that is.
You can get the
theoretical explanation
that big ships get
sucked to the sidewalls
by pressure differences
when travelling
at speed along canals.
But if that seems
a bit abstract,
you can learn it hands-on.
Because this is the
Port Iława Ship Handling
Research and Training Centre
in the north of Poland.
And this is one of the places
where the folks who
steer those big ships
learn how to do it.
Just to be clear, I'm not
getting a full training course.
That takes days
and includes
a huge amount of theory work
and study as well.
I'm just going to drive a
miniature container ship
for a lap around
the lake, and...
hopefully not get it
stuck in the Suez Canal.
We have started our
training activity in 1980.
In the '90s, we have moved from
the old lake towards this one,
and practically first training
here was realized in 1991,
more or less 30 years ago.
We are performing
training in ship handling.
We have a lot of
different mockups
presenting
different waterways.
Everything was built using
exactly the same scale, 1:24.
Deep waters,
shallow waters,
different restrictions,
rivers, canals.
And what is more important?
Of course, ship models.
Permission to come aboard?
Granted.
(laughs)
Okay.
This is bigger
than I thought
it was going to be.
It's one of the
biggest in the world.
400 metre ship.
400 metre?
Scaled down 1:24,
that's still...
16 and a half.
That's— Okay,
this is big, cool.
We can proceed.
Dead slow ahead.
So dead slow ahead?
Yep.
And steady as she goes.
Forward.
I assume that means just
keep it going straight, okay.
These are the
tugboat simulators.
Oh, I don't feel
guilty about you...
You've taken
the controls here.
I'd be on tugboats going out.
I was meant to be asking
all sorts of questions here,
and I'm just slightly nervous
about driving a tiny boat.
It's not a tiny boat.
It's a 400m container ship.
Yep. So you have
controls there
that simulate the effect
of tugs on the boat.
Right, four tugs.
You may make a
rather hard to port.
Hard to port?
I don't know why...
but I thought I was
going to spin that
like the wheel of a
pirate ship,
and it's just a...
Yeah.
Alright, so
what's our plan now?
Okay, so now we can go
through the lock if you like.
Yeah, absolutely.
Basically we go that direction,
south of the island.
I feel like I need
to go left here.
Yeah, make it port 10.
Port, not left.
We have had, in our history,
more than 6,000 pilots,
masters, and chief officers
from more than 50 countries.
On average, 220–230 a year.
We have beginners,
but we have also very
experienced masters.
Because the lock
is very shallow...
Yeah.
We will have
only 2cm of water
under the keel.
If we have too high a speed,
we touch the bottom.
So the faster I go
in shallow water,
the more the boat is going to
get sucked down to the ground.
More squat
you have, yeah.
We have to come
in line with the lock.
Oh!
Sooner we do that,
more time we have to apply
any correction if necessary.
That is such a tight
spot to navigate through.
Hard to starboard
for a while.
Hard to star—
Starboard, starboard.
The minute I feel like
I've got this...
It's all going to fall apart.
Uh, midships?
Yes, please.
Yep.
And starboard— yep.
Starboard 20.
And midships, yep.
Oh, I think I've
overcorrected there!
There's some very strong work
being done by the
tugboats here, thank you.
We have no clearance here!
I feel like starboard slightly?
Yeah, starboard 20.
Starboard 20.
(winces)
I can't see how
close we are there.
Did we clear that?
Yes.
I think we cleared that.
Yes!
(wheezes) Again,
solid tugboat work.
Midships, surely.
Starboard 20.
Okay!
The basic training
program takes five days.
A linear scale, 1:24, means
that timescale is equal
to more or less five.
It means everything happens
five times faster
than in reality.
And feeling for a ship
may be affected.
It's a disadvantage.
But on the other hand,
five days of training
will correspond to 25 days
of training in reality.
Hard to starboard.
I'm more the helmsman
than the captain
at this point, thank you.
Hard to port again.
Hard to port.
Left hand down a bit!
Okay, I think we
can make half ahead.
Half ahead.
We are clear of the lock.
Oh, yeah.
Phew!
Full ahead.
Full ahead!
(both laughing)
Did I need to slam that
forward so dramatically?
Absolutely not, but...
Our first models
were really very simple.
Nothing inside.
Just wheel,
engine telegraph,
and that's it.
And step by step...
we have started to add
different facilities.
We have electronic navigation.
It means a very precise
GPS system,
which allows to measure a
given ship model trajectory
with precision equal to
one, maybe two centimetres.
Suddenly the nerves
have gone.
Open ocean. Open lake.
Starboard 10.
'Cause you've
got to cancel out
what you've just given it, right?
Yeah.
We're still going
quite strongly to port
just because that input from...
The wind.
Ages ago, and the wind?
Due to the wind, yeah.
I'm amazed how much
the wind is affecting this.
You have to imagine
that such a ship, fully loaded,
has about 20,000
square metres
with the windage area.
(heavy sigh)
Everything during
exercises is measured,
sent to our classroom,
and in case of problems,
we can discuss step by step,
and we can show where
mistakes were made.
Ooh! ...I'm sorry, I got
distracted by a cormorant.
(both chuckle)
Current, especially in
the case of shallow water,
is a big problem.
It means we have
current generators.
This current velocity can be
changed according to our needs.
(metal colliding)
I thought we hit something.
Oh, we did.
That's me, sorry.
No problem.
(nervous chuckle)
It's not like this thing
has rear-view mirrors.
Okay, half ahead.
Half ahead?
We're sailing a
massive container ship
down the Suez Canal.
Do I need to put a little
bit of rudder in here?
Yeah, it's fine. Now you
have to go behind Varta.
Right.
You can make a port 10.
Port 10, got it.
I think we're clear
of the red buoy.
Midship.
Midships.
(winces)
No, no, it's clear.
Okay. Port 20.
Port 20.
Midships.
Midships. Okay.
And a full ahead.
Full ahead, okay!
Starboard 20.
Because we've got to
ease out the turn.
Then you will start
feeling the bank effect
from the starboard wall.
Okay.
Hard to starboard.
So it feels like
I could go midships now.
We should just go straight
down the middle of this canal.
Except...
The bank effect,
you see, bow is coming out.
It means the repulsion
force pushes the bow.
Now you have to make
a hard to starboard.
Hard to starboard.
Gah, yeah!
I'm being sucked
towards the port wall!
I'm putting full
right lock on here.
Midships.
Midships, okay.
You see, again, it's coming.
Yep... it is!
So we have to make
hard to starboard.
Hard to starboard, yeah,
if I don't do hard to starboard—
You would have hit this wall.
Yeah.
I'm absolutely gonna
ram that if we're not careful.
Yeah.
That's so powerful!
Midships.
Yep.
Yeah, hard to starboard.
Hard to starboard.
I was midships.
We should have been
going straight ahead.
And I think...
I think...
I have to help you
with that task.
Yeah, you're going
to have to help with that.
I should've done that earlier.
Everybody down.
Clear.
Oh, cleared?!
Midship. Hard to port now.
(bewildered laugh)
Hard to port.
You were lucky,
one inch clear.
That was more luck than
good judgment, that was!
Our research is focused
on ship handling.
It means interaction
forces, and...
autonomous ships.
We have started
realisation of
research programs
three or four years ago,
because...
autonomous ships
will be really very popular.
We need at least
ten ships' lengths...
Yeah.
...to stop the ship.
Ten ships' lengths?
And that harbour is here.
Oh, I definitely need
to put some port in.
Yes. Hard to port.
Port 20.
Hard to port, okay.
Everything in case
of our training centre
is realised in real conditions.
You can feel very well
wind,
you can feel very well
current,
and everything what deals
with weather conditions.
Such a situation
does not happen
in case when using
computer simulators.
And... especially
pilots coming to
our training centre for training
prefer very often to use
models instead of
computer simulation.
Every driver's
instinct in me is going,
"I can just slam it in reverse.
Take it 'round, it'll be fine."
No, it won't.
That's not how this works.
Collisions really occur
at our training centre.
The main difference regarding
computers and our models
is in computers,
in case of problems,
you can switch off everything,
and you can restart
everything. That's okay.
In the case of our
training centre,
the only one thing
to do is to...
call technical staff
for rescue tugs.
And quite often,
our models are sent
directly from the training
centre to our "shipyard"
for different repairing works.
And this psychological
effect influences
very much the
level of education.
People realise everything
a little bit differently
when comparing with
computer simulators.
Alright, we are home.
(sighs)
That was a privilege.
Thank you very, very much.
I know very few
people get to do that.
You're welcome, no problem.
So thank you so much.
Here, every
instructor can do that
(laughs)
...very easily.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]
There is one thing
I forgot to ask.
Can I push the whistle
button, please?
(blare)
Thank you! (laughs)